welcome to the program as we go on air
judges at the International Criminal
Court has sentenced a former Congolese
rebel leader for war crimes and sexual
slavery his Bosco gnihton ganda he was
also known as the Terminator he was
convicted of 18 war crimes and crimes
against humanity for the killings of
civilians and the Democratic Republic of
Congo it happened in the northeastern
Ettore region between 2002 and 2003 he
became the first person to be found
guilty at the hague of sexual slavery
he's facing now a 30-year prison term
for more on this let's bring in
Catherine soy who joins us from DOMA in
eastern DRC the latest on the sentencing
pretty much what the court was expected
to hand down Catherine the judges pizza
are still making that ruling so far what
they've done is give individual
sentences to all the editing pounds now
they're going to collapse all that each
one joins a sentence we're waiting to
hear the number of years yes I have just
gotten some information for our
producers he has been sentenced to 30
years in jail that's a maximum that he
could be sentenced to and all these has
made its banana a month a whole hour
that the judges were making this ruling
made a very grim reading they say they
found his involvement in atrocities
committed in villages in Eatery province
as substantial the crimes they said were
large-scale coordinated and the aim was
to drive out one ethnic community at
least into operation they said he
passionately gave orders and was
personally involved in some murder they
also say that in one incident he ordered
his militias to shoot at the civilians
that were fleeing they also talked about
sexual flavor and PITA
so that this is the first time that
someone has been convicted of sexual
slavery in the International Criminal
Court people are saying that he deserve
this punishment they were hoping for
life imprisonment we talked to some
people initially some of his victims in
history we also went to another area
called q1j where where I mean people
there are also saying that he committed
atrocities against him and they also
want justice Bosco Ntaganda has been
nicknamed by the people of eastern
Democratic Republic of Congo as the
Terminator
he's a former rebel leader accused of
human rights abuses in several parts of
the region judges are the International
Criminal Court
I found him guilty of crimes against
humanity and war crimes including murder
using child soldiers and sexual slavery
the crimes are committed in Italy
province between 2002 and 2003 by the
patriotic force for the liberation of
Congo revell group in tuganda led the
military wing Thomas Lubanga was a head
of the group and is serving 14 years in
jail at the ICC this man says his two
brothers were killed by the fighters we
lost many family members sisters
brothers uncles we also lost a lot of
properties eatery might be the focus of
antagonist case but in another town more
than 800 kilometers south victims of a
moussaka where a hundred and fifty
people were killed in one day in 2006
have been following court proceedings
Kinley they sent agonda was one of the
leaders of rebel fighters who attacked
their villages he said to have been
personal in charge of the q1j killings
almost everyone here in Q&A lost a loved
one those we talked to said Muslims and
Ganga and the fighters he led accuse
them of protecting a rival rebel group
they also say they want justice they
were born anew and I'm toto
Rebecca you may choose us Hoss cos she
says her husband and one-year-old son
what Celts in evidence a DNA what's
happening within tuganda should be a
deterrent to others who want to come and
terrorize us in the villages those
people destroyed our lives this part of
the country has been embroiled in armed
conflict for decades thousands of rebel
groups control remote villages and towns
campaigners want the government and
regional bodies to deal with human
rights abuses or fanic orgy Maru we need
a proper Court here with proper
investigators and justice system people
want to have their day in court and look
their perpetrators in the eye the ICC is
too far away and disconnected from
victims in the villages in tuganda is
the fourth person to be convicted by the
ICC during the South paw in it Tory says
he deserves to be in jail for life
Rebecca Newman Kwanza is still waiting
for her justice Catherine what kind of
reaction do you think this will generate
in the region well this is really -
double calling PETA I mean people in
Italy we've been talking to will
certainly be happy that justice has
finally been done either they said that
they'd waited for this for such a long
time but there's also disappointment for
those areas so these are people who've
suffered for so long some of them are
main their loved ones were killed some
of these are people who were killed were
breadwinners so they say they also
somehow want reparations and I mean just
to give you a small context of the
eastern DRC itself we have many rebel
movements or many rebel groups that are
controlling remote villages in this area
for many years even when Honda was
around so they say even if Bosco
Ntaganda has been sentenced we still
have a lot of security problems in
eastern DRC and they also want that
addressed we talked to that human rights
campaigner who was saying they want a
special court to address some of the
conflicts that are happening here some
of the human rights abuses as well so
people on the one hand happy that
justice has been made that perhaps this
will serve as a desire
to others but also saying that more
needs to be done to provide lasting
peace here in Italy I think Catherine
thanks very much